[Musik]
die zahlen von 21 bis 100
die lektion beginnt
guten morgen
die kamera
guten tag herr x euro in der letzten
lektion hatten wir die zahlen von null
bis 20 in der letzten lektion hatten wir
die zahlen von null bis 20
heute lernen wir die aussprache der
zahlen von 21 bis 100
auf
6 und
sich
[Musik]
viel hat sich
super
und jetzt nochmals alles nacheinander
21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 100 jetzt ihr los geht's
jetzt ihr los geht's
21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 100
bravo nach der pause gibt es einen
großen test
nach der pause gibt es einen großen test
pause
wie alt bist du eigentlich
was schätzt du
ich denke du bist 25 jahre alt
fast ich bin 26 jahre alt
fast ich bin 26 jahre alt welchem
jahrgang haben wohl unsere schulkollegen
welchen jahrgang haben wohl unsere
schulkollegen
ich denke ohne alt ist 1946 geboren
ich denke ronald ist 1946 geboren
ihr ab
immer noch
er arbeitet immer noch
ja er sollte endlich in den ruhestand
gehen
lasst uns schauen was die andere klasse
macht
[Musik]
zum glück sind wir nicht bei ihm weiß
die prüfung beginnt
welche zahl ist das
richtig
super
[Musik]
welche zahl ist das
genau
ronald welche zahl ist das
[Musik]
und 60
ich weiß es 69
bravo alle haben die prüfung bestanden
[Musik]
gratulation
gratulation www.hhl.de deutsch schule
punkt ch ist mutig dann drücke hier
möchtest du weiter dann abonniere den
kanal und leike das video plant wird
[Musik]